you might remember me from two of the
keynote demos that I done this morning
my job is a cloud developer advocate so
what we understand under the title is
basically either your software developer
if the license to speak or how I like to
introduce myself as like the
bi-directional channel of you developers
that build on our platform to the
developers inside Google that built this
platform so please feel free to reach
out to us to me personally you can reach
out on Twitter to me under the name
hacia wasti and we like to hear your
stories like how you use Google cloud
platform where you think it's
complicated and where we could do better
only with your feedback we can actually
improve our products now today I gonna
talk a bit about cloud spanner on one
hand about the history of cloud spanner
how we got about it in Google I will
provide some explanations what cloud
spanner is I also go down into some
architecture level and talk about the
technologies and the hardware that we
use to actually make that possible what
we can achieve
cloud spanner and I at the end I gonna
do some coding and show you a demo now
when I talk about cloud spanner and look
at the history of it we have to go back
at around 12 years to 2005
now Google at that point has been around
for a couple of years and our business
was growing massively so we had our
AdWords system on the back of a shorted
MySQL system now this MySQL system was
charted on the customer ID and we had to
recharge the system several times
the last time we restarted the system it
took actually several years and this was
not a solution that we could go forward
with the the way that we were growing
this was not a sustainable solution so
we needed something that can scale to
the point that we we needed it so we
needed something that horizontally
scales we had a lot of customer
to be recording click you quickly we
needed a system which is still strong
consistent and has like the relational
database attributes like the asset
transactions right so we were dealing
with money we were dealing in budgets we
had customers we had partners we had
HMCS so eventual consistency was not an
option for us
now also every minute the system was
stolen we and also our customers were
losing money so we couldn't accept any
downtime for the system we needed a
system where we can make changes where
we can they make updates where we can
make security patches without any
encourage downtime so prior to spanner
there was no system that could provide
all these qualities and that's the
reason we rebuild it ourselves now if we
look at cloud spanner compared to what
we have internally you get the same
system the same performance the same
consistency as the internal spanner that
we are using so it's the same site
reliability engineers that watching our
systems that also watching your systems
now as mentioned already we needed asset
transactions we need a global
consistency we actually have the highest
standard of the consistency the our
consistency model is external
centralized ability now one important
part was also that we wanted to tap into
the knowledge and the experience of our
developers we didn't want to put the
system in their hand which is completely
different to what they have been dealing
with all their like developer time or
like a developer life
so for us it was really important that
certain semantics are the same as you
would think of them in a traditional
relational database system on top of
this we added things like automatic and
synchronous replication so we can spend
more per each ons and we can actually
spend globally and out like in spanner
and for regional system that means that
we provide an SLA of four nines of
availability so this is about four
minutes and 38 seconds of downtime that
we allow per month now for our
multi-regional setups where you spend
your database over multiple regions and
we'll talk a little bit about what that
means
we actually provide an SLA with five
nines of availability which boils down
to about 26 seconds of allowed downtime
for months another really important
aspect for us when we were building
cloud spanner was to make it open to
enable customers and developers to adopt
it easily so when we started and when we
were working with our early access
customers we were focusing on making it
as easy as possible to adapt it so some
of these things are really sing standard
SQL ng 2011 we actually uses across most
of our products database products within
Google we added things like enterprise
features like encryption audit locking
identity access management things like
that
we spent quite some time and invested
some resources in building our client
libraries in major languages and there
are more and more of these client
libraries coming up where how to connect
automatically to cloud spanner and
currently in a read-only version we also
have a JDBC driver for cloud spanner
where you can connect your most favorite
like the eye tools directly to spanner
and and use them now how does it compare
with like one of the things that we
always get asked or like compared to is
on one hand like the traditional
relational database system and on the
other hand like the no SQL horizontally
scalable scalable database systems and
as you see here we put up with like a
small matrix of features that we are
comparing here so if you look at a
traditional odbms and you out scale this
system usually
what you're gonna do is you build like a
master replica system where you have
your master like a mascot a monster and
then you have a failover instance and
you might have some read replicas to
free up your master of right capacitive
read capacity to have more write
capacity on your master now if you want
to do any kind of maintenance on this
usually what you have to do is to fail
over to your failover instance if you do
maintenance on your master for instance
security patches or an update of the
version now that encourage downtime and
lose your money and it's quite some
operational risk that you incur there on
the other end if you look at like the no
SQL systems like if you basically out
coup image hearted traditional oughta be
mess many went through like no SQL and
we're looking at things like Cassandra
or other database systems that are out
there in the Noack NoSQL space but what
that meant is basically yes you do have
uniball consistency but most of the
times what we actually do to get
consistency what still is required in
many businesses is that you build this
consistency in transaction logic in your
application layer so you pull up this
logic into your application layer and
that makes it quite complex and
difficult and risky
so we've cloud spanner you basically can
move this logic back into into the
database and you still have these
qualities of a traditional database
system of asset transactions with the
scalability of a new SQL system so
typical workloads that we're seeing
especially with our early access program
members are can be put in like four
categories so the first one is if you
have like a transactional system think
of like an inventory management or
financial transactions or something like
that and you basically Sheryl Crow's
decides what your additional database
system can handle then that is like
we're spending an arm can come in you
still have like the need of transactions
but like your
traditional systems can't handle the
size of the database and span I can do
this for you like with the horizontal
scalability we can also scale at the
data size or the database size now if
you look at like one of the things that
we get asked often is also like well
it's loud span or only for big databases
and I have to say no like even if you
have small databases which are a couple
of gigabytes big but you have a lot of
traffic on this on this database and you
out scale your solutions in terms of
read and write transactions that you can
run this is another use case for cloud
spanner if you need to scale read and
write transactions another thing is if
you have mission-critical applications
so you really need a database system
that is available for nines or five
nines and you just can't make any
sacrifices on this again that is
something where cloud spanner comes into
the play the way that we architected
enables this high availability and
disaster recovery and in enables you to
basically build a global data plane
where you can have for instance if you
think of a supply chain management
system and you want to really know like
what items are still in your storage and
which items you have sold and things
like that you want to be as accurate as
possible and you want to have a few on
your data as a reason that's possible
and the force is if you think of systems
where you traditionally ETL data around
so for instance you have a user base in
a MySQL postcode a debase and then you
have like some log data or some audit
data in a Cassandra cluster and then at
the end of the day you ETL that into
another system and do some analytics on
this now this is again also a use case
for cloud spano since we can scale on
read and write as well as an on storage
you can combine and have these data
collocated in one database and do all
the analytic analytics there so to talk
a bit about more the architecture of
cloud spanner I want to
synchronize on on the terminology so to
say and everything in cloud spanner
starts with an instance so the instance
is basically where you define how many
nodes you want to have for your instance
so how what the scale the horizontal
scale of your instance and the capacity
of storage now in this instance you can
create a bunch of databases currently
the limit is set to 100 databases for
per instance and then in these databases
you can create tables currently per
database you can create about 2048
tables now this is basically what you
see as a developer and as a user to
enable us to distribute your data and to
distribute and scale on reads and writes
we have another concept underneath which
is the internal concept which we call
split now what is the split the split is
basically if you look at as a table and
you have your primary key we we divide
this table and we divide that based
lexicographically on the primary key so
or you could say also alphanumeric
ordering or alphabetical ordering
basically and we basically use ranges
and assign these splits to work on notes
now how does that look like so if you
look at an instance view of like of a
spanner instance you have in a regional
instance a distribution over three zones
so we have our compute on the top as you
can see one spanner node means you have
one compute node in each zone for a
regional instance so for regional that
means you have three compute nodes in in
three zones and then you have storage in
all of those like assign three that can
be used by these nodes so now if you
want to distribute the reads and writes
you basically take these splits and
assign these splits to a set of nodes
across these three nodes across these
three zones
but I mentioned earlier that we are
globally consistent so one of the
criterias here that is really really
important is that there's never more
than one group of notes responsible for
a split and we actually need one member
in this group who is the one the leader
of this group and what we are using to
do this is on one hand Texas so the
packs of algorithms basically allows us
to vote for a leader with a majority
voting and we need another thing to make
sure that we have exactly one paksas
group and exactly one leader for any any
split and what we use there is something
that we invented and called through time
now what is through time if you
synchronize your watches with your
neighbor and you go away and you come
back together in a week and you look at
your watches it's very highly likely
that your watches have drifted so they
drift because of cosmic rays they drift
because of different temperatures that
you have been there are many factors
that let your watch this drift now to
ensure for us that we have exactly one
leader we basically need something that
is close to a global wall clock time and
I mentioned ads banner is distributed
across the globe so we need something
where we can synchronize time across the
globe now it's not possible as I just
mentioned to just use a watch
synchronize it in one place and go
somewhere and distribute these watches
to all our data centers they will drift
away and they are not synchronized
anymore and then basically what could
happen is that you have two leaders for
the same split which means your data can
become inconsistent so what we needed is
basically we needed something to
quantify the trip that we have between
these data centers and we needed a
technology to synchronize all these
watches in our data center so what true
time does is actually it doesn't give
you a specific time through time gives
you an interval
so you have a lower bound and an upper
bound now the lower bound of you through
time time stems is at times them where
you know that this time stem has passed
all over the world do this times them
that you get as a lower bound has passed
you know that for sure now the upper
bound that you get is time stem that has
passed nowhere in the world and you can
be sure that this is the case now we use
this to select the leaders and make sure
that we have exactly one leader and one
taxes group for split and by that we can
ensure that we have global consistency
now how does it look in hardware we have
in all our data centers we have atomic
clocks and GPS receivers or time clocks
so to say and we use GPS to synchronize
the clocks around the globe and then we
have atomic clocks which we synchronize
with this GPS time masters and every
time we ask for true time timestamp or
interval we use a subset of our time
marshals that are available in our data
center and then we get it back and if
there's any outlier we basically can say
okay this atomic clock is bad we don't
care about this anymore and we use ones
that are looking more reasonable now we
synchronize these clocks we described in
our paper like roughly every 30 seconds
and as you can see there the clock drift
is about 200 microseconds per second and
so the interval that you get can get
down to like single-digit like very low
single-digit milliseconds so that
basically means all over the world we
can get an interval where we know like
the lower time stem and the the upper
time stem are not further away than two
milliseconds or maybe one millisecond
and we know that the lower bound has
passed everywhere and the upper bound
has passed nowhere and this enables us
to to do this close consistency now some
of you might ask what
and if like almighty atomic clocks fail
in the data center or all my time
masters fail in the data center now we
can still get these through time stamps
or timestamp intervals from a different
data center and we calculate like all
the like the the time of the
transmission and things like that what
basically means this interval becomes
bigger
maybe this interval is sent 10
milliseconds or 100 milliseconds which
basically means yes our database system
is slowing down but it's not stopping we
can still operate we just slow down a
bit and that I think is pretty amazing
now let's have a look at a more
practical practical example and I like
to explain that are based on and a life
of a query so in this case I am
selecting all events where the name is
cloud summit Paris so think of like the
agenda that we get back for this now the
client sends two requests and in our
case here it comes in to one of our
followers in this paksas group so we
have a leader and so in tune and we have
two followers in so in three and two and
one
now the request comes in through the
follower and so on one and that one will
basically ask the leader and say hey do
I have the most recent data like I am
seeing this timestamp of the data that
is requested is this the latest time
sent that you have now if the leader
says like yeah your your current I can
just serve that data from a follower and
I'm done now in the case that my request
comes in and my followers of my replica
in this case doesn't have the data the
leader will respond and say like no you
don't have the most current data but
just wait the data is already in flight
so just wait out at that time till you
have this times them of your data and
once you see that timestamp you can surf
the data because then you know for sure
that you have the most current data so
obviously just wait and then I sent the
response to my client now
another really powerful feature and
spanner is that you can do consistently
consistent stale reads now what does
that mean a consistent theory basically
means that you provide a boundary or you
provide a specific timestamp within
seven days where you say I want to see
the state of the database on that
specific time stem or I want to see the
state of the database and I don't care
if it's up to it let's say fifteen
seconds old now so basically in this
case I'm sending a request from my
client it comes in again through one of
the replicas and I say it's fine if this
data is 15 seconds old if there is
basically the data most in most of the
cases like in the most most most most
most of the cases this data will be
already at the replicas and they will
have a time stamp where they know okay
they can serve this data which is within
this boundary of 15 seconds staleness
and they can just respond to the client
we don't have to ask the leader or
anything and this is especially powerful
if you have a cloud spinner instance
that is globally distributed that is you
have it like let's say a read/write
master setup or readwrite quorum in the
US and then you have reach replicas in
Europe and in Asia now if you're if you
have agent liens coming in and they
don't care if they have the most current
data but they want to have a consistent
state of data they can be served with
data immediately from the read replicas
in a jar without consulting the
readwrite quorum in the US and that
speeds up your career is quite a bit now
if we look at the readwrite transaction
you can imagine in a readwrite on
section
I need the leader involved I'm changing
the state and I'm globally consistent so
I need some I need the leader to be
involved so in this case we are routing
the request directly to the leader of
the package groups that are involved so
if multiple pexif groups are involved we
use two-phase commit just to racy
communicate and so you can eyes between
them if a single packs of troopers
involve a cyclic an just do the
transaction within this package group
now in my example here I'm reading
I want to update my talk as you can see
here so the first thing that I do is I
do read I get my query result and
already acquiring some locks and then
I'm doing some changes I'm writing this
basically this mutation to a buffer and
then I'm committing this transaction and
the leader of a city at that time sends
out the write requests of this new data
to the followers of the replicas and as
soon as a quorum so the majority of that
Texas group responds with yes I have
written that data we basically can
respond to the client and say like your
transaction has been successful and we
can release the relax now as for the
data format or the Lea layout like what
we have in spanner is exactly what you
were like pretty much what you used to
from a traditional database system so we
have tables with columns that are
strongly typed as you can see here as an
example I have a singles table and an
albums table and I want to join them for
instance by the primary key in this case
I'm using the Singh ID as an example now
in traditional database systems you have
something like a foreign key constraint
they can say okay if I delete a singer I
want to have all my albums deleted as
well now in a distributed system this
becomes really complicated and very
harmful so we don't support this
semantics but we support a little bit
like foreign key constraint - -
semantics so in case you have something
we have tables that you join a lot and
where you want to be sure this data in
these tables is co-located we have a
construct that is called interleaved
tables so in interleaf tables what
happens is basically you interleave your
child table into a parent table based on
the primary key so the child table has
to has to basically preclude with the
primary key of the parent table and then
we basically can interleave this data
right where the where the parent rows
are
so basically what happens is they'll end
up they end up in the same split and as
you know like the split is managed by
one compute so one paksas group so we
don't have to go to like different
compute nodes and get all the data
together if we do this join every time
now you have to be a bit careful about
this don't overuse interleaving because
stress mentioned that it all ends up in
one split so you can run into things
like hot spotting or you can exhaust
actually the storage limits office split
so you have to be a bit careful there
now what does it look like in SQL on the
DDL statement you basically just add
like the interleaf in zingers interleave
in the parent table and then you can
like you can actually have multiple
levels of this interleaving if you need
to another powerful feature that I
mentioned earlier is online schema
updates so if you wanna like evolve your
application and you want to add columns
or things like that you can do that
while all your load is going on and it
is done in a transaction so they are
transactional consistent if you do
schema update for instance here I'm if
I'm changing my singles table and add a
column age I can do that inside a
transaction so there are a couple of
schema design don'ts which are coming
from the nature of this being a
distributed horizontal scalable database
so if you come from a MySQL or post
casserole this is not a lift and shift
that you can do you not can you can't
take your application that you've pulled
on on on top of my scale or Postgres and
just move it over you have to do some
redesigning and some changes on your
schema in most of the cases so one of
the things that are really harmful in in
spanner are things like an outer
increment in Tetra so think of like auto
increment feature in my scale where like
every time I insert a row it get
automatically assigned a new ID now if
we have like these we have monotonically
increasing numbers and as I mentioned
earlier we are doing
it's by Lexus like by alphabetically
ranges alphabetically sorted ranges or
lexicographic ranges now you can imagine
if you have an monotonic increasing ID
or time stems for instance every time
you insert data it basically gets
inserted into your last split and your
hot spotting on your last split even
though you might have thousand splits
for your table and you always insert row
with the most current timestamp you're
basically sending all this data to the
last split and by that you restrict your
scalability and your hotspot on that
split again also with interleaving the
same problem like if you inter leave a
lot of data into one row into one parent
row you interleave all this data into
one split and again you can also cause
hot spotting so be careful with how deep
you go and like how much data you
interleave into a parent table so just
to give an example is this a little bit
more graphically here if you have a
timestamp as a primary key like a lot of
success timestamp for instance and then
user ID and some other data for each of
euros since it's lexicographic you
ordered you get all these into one split
so what can you do to avoid this hot
spotting so one of the things that you
can do is using use you IDs and they're
preferable version four or later as a
primary keys you can do things like that
you add a charting counter or charting
ID to your data in front like we had a
charting IDE to your timestamp and
things like that so as an example here
again same table as you saw before we
have our last success times then we have
our user ID and we just add in front of
it a shorting ID and by a heading the
shorting ID now we can actually
distribute the load of inserts or
updates on this row across multiple
splits and you're not hot spotting on a
split so with this I hope you got some
insights on like how loud spinner works
under the hood and what things to pay
attention to and now I want to show a
little bit demo and want to show
little bit like how you can get started
with cloudspinner so please switch to
the demo laptop okay perfect so your
first stop is cloud spanner or cloud at
google.com slash spanner which is
basically your intro page into into
cloud spanner and has a multitude of
information linked from there I want to
point out a couple of things or actually
one thing down here there has been a
couple of case studies studies with our
early access members for cloud spanner
and one of them is Quizlet that moved
from a shorted MySQL system to cloud
spanner and they talked and like very
technical and very detailed about their
transition from my Scott and MySQL
system to cloud spanner so if you were
in the situation that you have a shorted
system and you want to explore cloud
spanner this is a good start to look
into like how what are the things to pay
attention to another thing that we
sometimes get asked is does cloud
spanner defeat the cap theorem now like
if you look at distributed systems and
you know like Eric Brewer he like came
up with the cap theorem where you have
to basically choose two out of three of
consistency availability and
partitioning so like you can't have a
consistent consistent available system
that is also petitioned all right things
like that and now it's a mask like okay
the spanner actually defeat the cap
theorem and the answer is no like if
loud spanner becomes partition to the
thing that we don't have a majority
anymore for our taxes groups we default
to a consistent system and become
unavailable but the likelihood is very
very really low otherwise we wouldn't
give out the nestled a of four nines
four regional or five nines for
multi-regional because of the system and
the hardware that we have underneath and
the way the spanner was architectured
this likelihood of of a split brain how
it's called sometimes is very very low
now another thing that I want to point
out is if you look into building a new
application
or like migrating and application please
read our white papers that we have
linked in the documentation which talks
a lot about do's and don'ts in terms of
schema design and create design there
are some specifics to cloudspinner to
get the most out of it and we want to
enable you to get the most out of it so
for the ones that have seen the keynote
demo this morning you already know how
to create a spanner instance I just want
to show that really quickly again this
is basically the home screen if you've
created a project in the cloud console
so let me actually sum this up a little
bit so if you want to go to spanner you
have multiple options to go to spanner
your eyes that can use the hamburger
symbol here on the left and and look for
it loud spanner you can type in into
this field up here in the search or if
you a whim user you know how to search
and BIM basically you slash and I
automatically focuses into the search
box and then you can do a spanner and
click on it and your head spam now to
create an instance I just click on
create an instance I name it
I let select configuration that's to
Europe and I say like five notes and I
create and as seen in the architectural
overview that I've shown no I have no I
have no sufficient cool let's do one and
fingers crossed that works so as you've
seen in the architectural diagram we are
actually distributing and separating the
compute and storage to enable the
horizontal scalability now to create a
database we do the same thing like I
create I say I want to have a demo
database I can use our dialogues to
create a schema for instance if I want
to have a singers table I create a
singles table I'm adding a column for
instance age do int I create I have to
select the primary key and then I click
create and again within a couple of
seconds you have your database now just
to show you if I wanna
this I can do an edit schema again I can
use TTL or our dialog and I can say for
instance city and I'm adding string and
who's done and then save and as you will
see in a second there's a box coming up
which shows that this is basically
running in a transaction the scheme
update so as soon as this transaction
has finished the new schema will be
available now I want to switch a little
bit to more like complex schema and
again you might remember that one from
the keynote demo I basically have the
scenario of a ticket broker where you
have event organizers want to sell
tickets and then you have customers or
fans at one of buy tickets and I just
came up with like sample application to
to represent such a system now what you
have in this is on one hand for instance
if you want to have tours like that to
Springsteen tour sting tour or whatever
called Louie Courtley you have a multi
event which includes basically multiple
events in different cities then you have
the events for each event we need a
venue so you see when you are up there
as well
and then each of these venues has
different seating categories and
configuration so you can for instance
have general admission you can have
premium seating you can have VIP and all
these have different prices assigned so
it gets like if you think about it like
complex quite quickly now I did one
thing here as you can see I interleaved
the venue into at the seating category
actually into the venue because I'm I'm
doing this joy in very often so I wanted
to have actually the seating category
co-located with my venues so I used the
interleaving in this case all the other
things are basically standalone tables
and I can join them by by IDs as I wish
so the first thing that I want to do is
and then in my case here I'm using Java
is to show you how to get started with
Java and
connecting against cloud spanner now
just to check how many Java developers
do we have here in the room okay how
many go developers all right see you the
cool kids on the block
peyten oh wow I should have done a
Python demo alright next time
so in this case I hope you bear with me
Python and go Forks that hopefully you
can read my java code so the first thing
that we want to do is we want to
authenticate now if you run this on your
local machine and have that set up with
the G cloud SDK or you run it on any of
our GCE instances or inside kubernetes
you get a default authentication context
on these machines and you can just use
this so this is really easy I'm just
saying Google credentials that get
application default and I'm
authenticated so I think this is amazing
just imagine like what you have would
have to do with all kinds of things of
keys and oh yeah it gets messy and I
wouldn't be able to do this in the time
that I have left now in case you need to
authenticate with the key we also have
the possibility that you create a JSON
key like a service account and then you
use that or authenticate against
cloudspinner now the next thing is I
need a client stuff so I need to say
which instance am I going to talking to
which database am I going to talk into
and use all this information like the
project ID and things like that come
from this authentication context and
then I create a database client so as
you can see here I'm creating my client
next thing is what I want to do is in
this case it's a read-only transaction
so read-only transaction the advantage
of this is I don't need to acquire any
locks so I can just do this so I want to
have a read-only connection and you
basically what you do is the beat line
that single use for your read-only
transaction in our case and then I want
to of course
run a query so here in this case I'm
looking for our multi events that are
happening from right now till tomorrow
so 24 hours later so as you can see here
I'm using a statement builder and I can
put parameter placeholders and then bind
these parameters down here as you can
see so I'm using basically for the date
times them now and then for the next day
I'm creating a new timestamp where I'm
adding 24 hours and last but not least I
of course want to show this and iterate
through my result set so I basically
just like as we know from iterate able
we just iterate through the list we
don't have any results at left and I can
point through the results in my from my
query either by location so ID and they
say it's like you see get string i0
which basically means I want to have the
first precision of my query or you can
also use the column names if you use
them so I could use basically multi
event ID for instance as to get the
element the value of this for this row
for this column and then I can run all
this and fingers rust it hopefully works
so see I also limited to 10 results so
we see that at once now this took a
little bit and that is because like
creating the connection to cloud spanner
takes a little bit of time if I would
run it like multiple times with the
connection standing it gets much much
faster so you get to single digit query
response times actually now I mentioned
that we can do stale consistent reads
and what I can do is I just modify my
single read only transaction and I'm
adding a time bound so as you can see up
there I'm adding a timestamp bound of a
max stillness stillness of 15 seconds
and by that basically if I come into a
follower or replica the replica can
respond with the data right away so we
can just run this again and you will see
that we get some data
back as well now the next thing that I
want to show is a read-only transaction
now I have all this step stopped here
already so this is just a repeat
repetition so icon has jumped right away
to the insert transaction now what I do
here is a write only transaction and
first of all what I have to create as a
mutation so we don't have currently DML
you can do you can't do like insert into
and things like that but we use you can
use the client libraries and they have
an IO Matic way of inserting data now
there's something that we use is called
mutations and I want to imply
collaborate a little bit on this in
spanner a mutation is basically a change
of a cell like a modification of itself
so that means if you have a table with
five columns and you insert a row you
have five mutations now why do I mention
that the thing is for transaction we
have a limit of 20,000 mutation per
transaction and you have to be aware of
this if you are adding indexes on your
table for instance we have our five
column table and we edit in India we add
an index with three columns where we do
an index on three of the five colors
then we basically have for each row that
we add in our table we have eight
mutations five for the table and three
for the index and it's really really
important to remember if you ever see
that error like exceeding mutations
limit that you think of like okay a
mutation is not one row of one mutation
a mutation is one row multiply it by
columns and so on and so on so in this
case I'm creating an account I'm adding
like my name like email address and
everything and then I run this there's
one thing that I want to mention yep
basically here you see I'm basically
doing DBE client that right and I
provide these mutations and I'm just
writing that so this will return me with
timestamp when this has been written now
we have this in the database and I can
show that really quick
we have I have here my demo instance and
I going to go to the accounts and if we
go to data we're gonna see here my data
that just got insert now one of the
things that I want to do is if I want to
do a read write write so I have to
create like a transaction context in my
in my client and then do the read which
I can do either through the read API or
I can use SQL so in this case I'm
creating this read here and then my
mutation but there's something special
about this construct as you can see here
we do this read write transaction and we
provide a transaction runner transaction
caller bill now why are we doing this as
you can see here we basically provide
the clients library a complete function
of this transaction and that enables us
from the client side to rewrite in to
rerun your transactions in case it fails
so you basically provide us all what it
has to be done in this transaction and
we can rerun it on the client side if if
there should be any problems with this
so again if we run this I'm just
basically selecting my account and then
changing my name from Robert to spanner
guru so if we go back here and go to our
account table to my data we now see that
my name has changed and then I could do
this also programmatically but we just
recently added this feature in our cloud
console that you can now also edit data
right here or delete it in my case I
want to clean up after myself and so I
delete this data this is back to the
slides
so with one minute left I just want to
mention like briefly the other database
products that we have in our cloud
platform portfolio so our database
products range from you know in-memory
databases to like the data warehouse
databases so if you for instance build
on App Engine you can use our App Engine
memcache if you look at a relational we
have a managed database service where
you can have my SQL or Postgres as a
managed solution which can be set up
with fail over and read replicas but
that is a vertical scalable solution now
if you need horizontal scalable solution
for the criteria that I mentioned
throughout this talk you're looking at
spanner if you look at like more than no
SQL databases we have two offerings one
on one hand loud datastore which is more
like a document store and then we have
cloud BigTable which is key values for
which can have like a immense throughput
and scale if you need on the throughput
side and also on the query side in terms
of like single digit career response
times even if you have terabytes of data
in your database
now cloud datastore supports you from
small applications up to huge
applications just think like snapchat
built their entire application on data
store and dep engine and then if you
look more unto like object solutions you
can look into cloud storage where you
can save basic blobs like video files
anything
the nice thing about cloud storage is
also it's backed by spanner again and it
enables you to if you store a file and
you look anywhere in the world on the
state of like how what kind of files you
have in your buckets you will see a
consistent state across the globe so if
your data like if your data is there you
will see it from everywhere and that's
enabled by cloud spanner
now if you want to do analytics we have
a like cloud native solution like fully
managed solution called bigquery and
bigquery is amazing to crunch through
terabytes even petabytes of data in
seconds or very little minutes so if
you're looking at like lower your costs
of ownership in doing analytics bigquery
is one one of your things we really
should look into with this thank you
very much I hope you enjoyed this talk
and enjoy the rest of the day
[Applause]